with just a single word Oda sparked an
insane amount of fan hype and
speculation about who the rulers of the
world really are who the strongest
characters in the series are and how
this all relates back to the secret
history of the world and the people who
are freaking out about this are right
Oda did just drop a massive clue about
the void Century the ancient Kingdom and
how the gorosei took over the world even
the true nature of the one piece and the
ending of the entire story may have been
spoiled with this one word so let's get
into it you guys know the drill if you
enjoy our one piece content and you want
to see more in the future leave a quick
like and comment right now it only takes
you a second but it helps pump up that
YouTube algorithm and by the way over 50
of you guys who watch our videos are not
subscribed to the channel do me a big
favor and subscribe right now it's
completely free and it helps me out a
lot on YouTube finally this video will
contain one p these manga spoilers so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned in chapter 1073 of the manga
the full name of one of the gorosei was
finally revealed the gorosejar of course
the five Celestial Dragons Who control
the world the government and whose
authority is second only to the
mysterious imusama the gorosei first
appeared all the way back in chapter 233
of the manga and their name gorosei has
been translated as the five elders and
the five Elder Stars however as we
learned recently gorosei may actually
mean five Elder planets the full name of
one of the gorosei the one with the
white dreadlocks is Saint Jay Garcia
Saturn and his name reveal continues a
very clear Trend in the one piece Story
the trend I'm referring to is an
increased focus on outer space and
celestial bodies with the most obvious
example being the reveal of son one God
Nica but in reality space and celestial
bodies have been given a lot of
attention by Oda from the very beginning
and I'm not just talking about all the
basic sun and moon symbolism because
there's a lot of that as well I'm
referring to stuff like the fact that
the world Nobles call themselves
Celestial dragons and most of them wear
outfits that look almost exactly like
space suits on top of that thanks to
announce travels we learned that there
was an entire ancient civilization that
once resided on the moon this highly
Advanced civilization left the moon due
to a lack of resources and they settled
on Earth over 1 100 years ago so
hundreds of years before the void
Century members of this Moon
civilization had unique characteristics
like extremely advanced technology a
distinct way of dressing and wings on
their backs the moon people who left the
moon and emigrated to Earth over 11
centuries ago are the ancestors of
modern day skypeens shandians and
Birkins from anell's Adventures on the
moon we also learned that space pirates
exist in the world of One Piece which
again suggests that space is an
important aspect of the one-piece World
outer space in one piece is not just an
empty expanse without oxygen or gravity
like the outer space in our own world
space in one piece appears to have
oxygen gravity and inhabitants the moon
civilization were once permanent
residents of the moon and the space
pirates also presumably live somewhere
in space so what about the five elders
and why are people saying that they may
actually represent the five Elder
planets in our own world the five
planets that were discovered first
because of their proximity to the Earth
are Mars Mercury Venus Jupiter and of
course Saturn humans have been aware of
their existence since ancient times and
they may have been discussed covered as
far back as four thousand years ago the
three outer planets were discovered much
much later after the invention of
telescopes these three include Uranus
which was discovered in the 1700s
Neptune which was discovered in the
1800s and finally Pluto which was
discovered in 1930. Pluto was initially
classified as the ninth planet in our
solar system but in 2006 its
classification was downgraded to dwarf
planet it's worth noting that this
change in Pluto's classification came
well after one piece started being
published interestingly enough the three
outer planets of our solar system
correspond with the three ancient
weapons in the world of One Piece Uranus
is of course one of the weapons pluton
is the original Greek name for the Roman
god Pluto and Poseidon is of course the
original Greek name for the Roman god
Neptune so if the three outer planets
inspired the names of the three ancient
weapons then what about the five Elders
well we now know that one of the others
is named Saturn and since there are five
of them and there are five Elder planets
we could assume that each one of them
has been named after one of these
planets as Artur from the library of
Ohara pointed out in a recent video in
Japanese the word gorosei can be
translated as not just five Elders or
five other stars but also as five Elder
planets this constitutes strong evidence
that the names of each of the five
Elders could correspond to the five
Elder planets I will link Arthur's video
down in the description because his work
is always great and in that same video
Arthur points out that the famous globe
that we see in O'Hara may not actually
show what many fans thought it was
showing all this time the globe depicts
the Earth in the center then a small
round object which corresponds with the
Moon that NL visited and then five other
circular objects that are considerably
larger than the moon but smaller than
the earth these objects have different
colors and different markings on their
surface initially many people thought
that because they are smaller than the
earth they must also be moons that
circulate the Earth in the world of One
Piece meaning that the Earth in the
world of One Piece has six different
moons which is of course very different
from our world which only has one but
what if the other five round objects are
not actually moons but separate planets
altogether what if these are the five
Elder planets in the world of One Piece
the globe on O'Hara is not actually to
scale and it is simply showing the
planets as they appear from Earth rather
than showing them in their true size or
in their true location in relation to
the sun they may of course be as big as
the Earth or even bigger but because
they are so far away they appear to be
way smaller to someone who is observing
them from Earth this means that along
with the moon there are at least five
observable planets in that solar system
and each of the five Elders may be named
after one of these planets what's more
since we know that space in the world of
One Piece has oxygen and gravity it is
possible that one or more of these
planets have the kind of atmosphere
angiography that can support Advanced
human life since NL can reach the moon
with a ship like the arc Maxim and since
space pirates can travel through outer
space in their own ships we have to
assume that the inhabitants of these
other planets could potentially reached
the Earth just as someone from Earth
could potentially reach these other
planets we don't know how far these
planets are from the earth in the world
of one piece but they may not be nearly
as far away as the five other planets
are from the earth in the real world and
if these planets are not insanely far
away and if it is possible to travel
through space by ship then we cannot
exclude the possibility that there are
civilizations on these other planets and
they may have even made some contact
with the civilizations of Earth at some
point in the past this could be the key
to everything this one piece of
information could explain the ancient
war the void Century the secret origins
of the celestial dragons and the true
nature of the one piece after all we
know that the moon civilization had
advanced technology and that they were
able to travel from the moon to the sky
islands and down to the surface of the
Earth the one piece
Odyssey game even features an offshoot
tribe from the Birkins who created a
fourth ancient weapon capable of
destroying the entire world although the
games are not canon this still hints at
the possibility that other ancient
weapons could potentially have
extraterrestrial Origins this is
extremely important because the
celestial dragons themselves and the
gorosei and imusama in particular may
also have extraterrestrial Origins what
if I told you that the real reason why
the world Nobles refer to themselves as
Celestial dragons why they wear
spacesuits and why they act like they
are gods among men is because the
current rulers of the world are
literally from outer space what if the
celestial dragons or at least those who
really matter and who really run things
originated on other planets and then
came to Earth during the void Century as
conquerors just like the moon
civilization came down to earth over 11
centuries ago due to a lack of resources
on the moon itself elf it's possible
that during the void Century a
civilization from another planet invaded
the Earth this Alien Invasion waged war
against the ancient Kingdom which was
defending the Earth from the foreign
Invasion the Invaders eventually won by
making an alliance with a bunch of Earth
kingdoms who may have been living in the
shadow of the ancient Kingdom and so
they saw the Alien Invasion as an
opportunity to advance their own
interests by supporting the Invaders
against their biggest Rivals these
kingdoms were eventually rewarded by
having their royal families join the
Invaders as the Undisputed rulers of the
world as gods among men and yes I know
this all sounds crazy I literally sound
like that guy from Ancient Aliens who
thinks that the answer to all of
History's Mysteries is just aliens but
if we were to suspend disbelief and
consider the possibility that some of
the rulers of the world actually came
from other planets then this really
would explain a lot why are ibusama and
the gorosei so desperate to erase an
entire Century from history why don't
they want anyone to know what really
happened during the ancient war well if
we presume that the ancient War was
waged between Alien Invaders and an
ancient Kingdom that was valiantly
defending the Earth from Invasion then
the world Nobles would lose all
legitimacy in the eyes of the people the
people would know that these Celestial
dragons are not the rightful rulers of
the world they are actually foreign
Invaders and colonizers and the people
of the world would be justified in
opposing them so the truth had to be
hidden at all costs this would also
explain why the lunarians were violently
forced out of their Homeland on top of
the red line and driven to the brain
drink of Extinction we know that in
ancient times the lunarians were thought
of as gods and their Homeland on top of
the red line was a place that commanded
a lot of respect and reverence in fact
the lunarians themselves may have been
an offshoot tribe of the Moon
civilization or another extraterrestrial
civilization given their wings and
unique powers and abilities but that's a
topic for another video If foreign
Invaders wanted to ensure that the local
population would obey and respect them
what better way to do it than to defeat
the old gods usurped their Homeland and
then Proclaim themselves to be the new
gods of the world there are a lot of
things that we can learn about a
potential alien invasion in one piece
from the real-life invasion of the
Americas by European conquistadors
during the so-called age of Discovery
although both sides were from the same
Planet this was still a case of two
completely different worlds colliding
and people who had no previous contact
with each other suddenly coming face to
face
interestingly enough the rulers of
ancient mesoamerica would often equate
themselves with Quetzalcoatl an
important Aztec god who is described as
a feathered serpent almost like a
Celestial Dragon but moving on Aztec
rulers who claimed to be Quetzalcoatl
were implying that they were this God's
current Incarnation or reincarnation on
Earth and that gave them the Divine
Right to rule the Aztec people believed
that Quetzalcoatl would one day return
to Earth and according to some
historical sources when Hernan Cortes
and the Conquistadors landed in America
in 1519 many Aztecs believed that Cortes
was actually Quetzalcoatl returning to
claim his throne According to some
sources even the Aztec Emperor Montezuma
II believed this to be the case this was
partially because the strange technology
and fashion of the Europeans convinced
some people that they must be divine
visitors rather than normal humans but
regardless of how exactly this belief
took root it obviously helped the
Europeans to gain a foothold in the
newly invaded territory I mean just
think about it no one wants to oppose a
god gods are meant to be obeyed and
respected so if you want to successfully
rule a newly conquered land pretending
to be a literal God is like the best
possible strategy Oda has referenced the
Spanish conquest of the Americas on
multiple occasions and most prominently
in skypeia for instance the shandians
are clearly inspired by Native Americans
and gonfall's armor seems to be directly
inspired by The Conquistadors knowing
how important skypeia turned out to be
in hindsight I wouldn't be surprised if
these references to the European
conquest of the Americas were
deliberately foreshadowing the true
origins of imusama and the gorosei what
better way to conquer a newly invaded
land than overthrowing the former Gods
occupying their holy land and rebranding
yourself as the true gods of the world
now let's talk about Saturn which as I
said is part of the newly revealed full
name of one of the gorosei Saint J
Garcia Saturn this single word could
tell us a lot about where Oda is going
next with the story and believe it or
not even just a little bit of research
into the meaning of Saturn provides
further evidence that there might be
something to the Alien Invasion Theory
now of course Saturn is the name of one
of the five inner planets in our own
world and it could be the name of one of
the five planets in the world of one
piece but that is not confirmed yet in
our own world the planet Saturn was
named after the Greco-Roman god of time
abundance wealth and a bunch of other
things fun fact but Saturday the actual
day of the week is also named after him
the Roman Saturn is equated to the Greek
Titan Cronus who famously overthrew his
own father Uranus the sky God Saturn
then reigned over a mythological Golden
Age period which was a time of P peace
and abundance now there's an interesting
thing about Saturn that I didn't even
know until I started doing research for
this video in some of the Roman
mythological Traditions Saturn was known
as an immigrant God according to these
Traditions Saturn was expelled from
Greece by his son Jupiter and he then
emigrated to Rome where he was welcomed
by the Roman God Janus so Saturn became
a foreigner God in Rome a foreign ruler
who was nevertheless worshiped and
obeyed by the Romans they even named one
of their greatest festivals after him
saturnalia and some of the most
important temples in Roman religion were
dedicated to Saturn Saturn was accepted
as a king in Rome because he was able to
take an unruly and Scattered people and
unite them all and give them laws now
yes I am diving pretty deep into
Greco-Roman mythology here but to be
fair Oda loves mythology and he has
referenced many mythological traditions
in one piece including Greek and Roman
because of that I firmly believe that
studying mythological Traditions
including Greek Roman Norse Egyptian
Mesoamerican and of course Japanese can
give us real clues about where he's
going with the story and if the name Jay
Garcia Saturn is a clue that like the
Saturn in Roman mythology Saint J Garcia
Saturn is a foreigner on immigrant God
in the world of One Piece then the final
song of the story May really take us
where many have been predicting that it
will go all along Outer Space if the
ancient war was a clash between Earthly
kingdoms and extraterrestrial Invaders
who ultimately conquered the Earth and
created the world government much like
the European colonists conquered the
Americas and then set up their own
governments there then the search for
the truth about Joy boy and the one
piece will inevitably take us into space
ever since I first read the Odin
flashback one small detail has bothered
me about Roger's famous visit to
laughtail if the ancient war occurred
between 900 and 800 years ago then why
would Rogers say that he was too early
too early after eight freaking centuries
that doesn't seem quite right now sure
we can say that he was too early because
Joy boy had not yet reawakened inside of
Luffy but we only know that in hindsight
how would Roger know that joyboy had not
yet returned I mean he would know that
he isn't Joy boy and the joy boy wasn't
on his crew but how would he know that
joyboy wasn't already out there
somewhere maybe on the other side of the
world how could Roger have known that
only several years after his death a boy
would be born who would one day awaken
the Nika devil fruit and Usher in the
return of Joy boy this might sound crazy
but when I read this as I was catching
up to the manga for the first time
through the one piece virgin podcast my
first thought was this is there some
kind of cosmic event that only happens
once like every 800 years and was this
Cosmic event somehow related to Joy boy
laughtail and the one piece I quickly
realized that there are in fact comets
within our own solar system that are
only visible to us every 700 800 or even
900 years
so what if the one piece is in fact in
outer space but it's not on the moon or
another planet rather it's on a comet
that only appears once every 800 years
what if Joy boy left his treasure on
this Comet knowing full well that no one
will be able to get to it until it made
its way all the way around the solar
system and approached the Earth again
800 years later this would be the
perfect hiding place because it would be
completely safe for that period of time
and if anyone tried to find it before
that they would soon learn that they
were too early that said if anyone was
able to find it at precisely the right
time they would be able to gain access
to it we can assume that the information
about all of this and the instructions
for how to actually reach the treasure
were hidden away on laughtail Roger and
his crew found the instructions on
laughtail and then after realizing what
the treasure was they knew that they
were too early that's because the comet
would not arrive for at least another
two and a half decades and what is the
one piece treasure is it something
hidden on the Comet or within the Comet
or could it be the comet itself I've
always believed that the one piece would
be something that actually plays an
important role in the story I think the
treasure will be something tangible that
can actually be used for a greater
purpose so I don't think it's just
riches or just information even though
both of those things will likely be a
part of the treasure I think the one
piece is more likely to be something
like a weapon and this weapon will allow
Joy boy to defeat the Invaders of the
earth and the usurpers of the red line
the world Nobles so I am leaning towards
the theory that the one piece will be a
battleship and perhaps it will be a
flying Battleship a spaceship that was
used to resist the Extraterrestrial
invasion of Earth during the ancient war
800 years ago this ship may have been
hidden away on top of a comet after the
war was lost or it may may be the comet
itself but when the time is right this
ancient weapon will be used to bring
down the world government and Liberate
the world after all Dr vegapunk
confirmed that the ancient weapon
possessed technology that is far more
advanced than the technology of the
present day so it is certainly possible
that the ancient Kingdom created a
futuristic spaceship and it is possible
that the comet itself might be the
source of the mysterious ancient energy
that vegapunk is looking for we know
that the third ancient weapon Uranus is
associated with the sky because Uranus
is the sky God in Greek mythology in
fact Uranus was actually overthrown by
his son Cronus also known as Saturn as
of right now many people believe that
the flying weapon imusama used to
destroy lolucia in chapter 1060 is
Uranus itself that could very well be
true but just in case eem's weapon isn't
one of the three ancient weapons that
are described on the poneoglyphs then
Uranus would still be out there and it
could turn out to be a spaceship at the
same time even if Uranus is imusama's
secret weapon the one piece itself could
be another weapon on top of the three
ancient weapons that we already know
about whatever happens in the end the
latest crazy reveals that we've gotten
in the Egghead Arc really got me
thinking about the ancient war and what
happened during the void Century at the
risk of sounding like the aliens guy
from The History Channel I am definitely
intrigued by the idea that the rulers of
the world government might actually be
from one of the five planets in the
world of one piece that would explain so
much in terms of the celestial dragons
from the very name Celestial dragons to
having a name with the word Saturn in it
and to their desperate need to portray
themselves as Gods while doing
everything they can to erase the truth
about the void Century that said it
could also be that only a few of the
world Nobles are aliens and the others
are just members of royal families who
betrayed their own planet in order to
side with the Invaders the only true
foreign rulers on Earth might be the
gorosei and emu or maybe even just
imusama him or herself perhaps that is
why we still haven't seen what eema
really looks like because he or she has
a distinctly alien appearance and Oda
doesn't want us to connect all the dots
just yet at the same time Aliens could
look a lot like humans anyway as we saw
with the moon civilization and I mean
for all we know the moon and all the
other planets in the solar system could
have been colonized by humans from Earth
thousands of years ago since their
technology was actually more advanced
back then they could have established
colonies on the other planets and so
when they eventually came back to Earth
they were simply returning to where
their ancestors came from there are many
possible scenarios and this is all such
fascinating stuff and in the end I know
that Oda will not disappoint us the
ending of One Piece will be out
absolutely incredible and the massive
reveals about the void century and the
one-piece treasure will definitely shock
everyone what do you guys think kuri
musama and maybe even the gorosei be
extraterrestrial Invaders who conquered
the Earth during the void century and
then did their best to erase that truth
from history could the one-piece
treasure be on top of a comet that only
appears once every 800 years or could it
be the comet itself did aliens build the
pyramids and create Bitcoin let me know
down in the comments below if you're
looking for a video to watch next check
out this video that explains all the
Warlords and their powers link is on
screen and in the description if you
enjoyed this one piece video and you
want to see more leave a quick like
right now and if you're still not
subscribed to the channel do me a big
favor and make this the video that you
subscribe and hit that notification Bell
to turn on all notifications as always
thank you guys so much for watching and
until next time see ya Space Cowboys